in late 2016 elon musk revealed his
vision for solar roofs
in an effort to convince shareholders
that bailing out solarcity was the right
move
unlike regular solar panels that were
bulky and arguably take away from the
look of the house
solar roofs were supposed to look like
regular roof shingles
nearly five years later though we
haven't really seen solar roofs roll out
in a grand fashion
moreover solar city or now tesla energy
continues to face major issues when it
comes to liquidity and
profitability despite getting a bailout
and being in business for 15
years so what happened to solarcity
well taking a look back solarcity was
founded on july 4th 2006
by lyndon and peter reeve though these
two were technically the founders and
the ones who ran the business day to day
the backbone of the company was elon
musk from day one
after hitting the jackpot with paypal
elon was looking to work on something
that was more
meaningful and impactful the two sectors
that he thought were most important
were space and sustainable energy in
terms of space
he of course had spacex and in terms of
sustainable energy
he had tesla but he really wanted to do
something
in the solar energy sector so he would
pitch the idea to his cousins
lyndon and peter reeve willing to give
the idea a try
linden and peter would start the company
with the 10 million investment from elon
within just 12 months
the company would hire 150 employees and
growth in selling 70 solar systems
per month from the very beginning though
linda knew that the biggest barrier for
success
was the high cost of purchasing and
installing the solar panels
so he pitched a new business model that
would eliminate the upfront cost for the
customer
the idea entailed solarcity owning the
solar panels
and the company paying for the
installation costs customers would
essentially rent the panels and to pay
solarcity
for the power generated by the panels
this agreement was called a ppa
or a power purchase agreement and they
would typically last 20 years
customers also had the option to finance
the panels and eventually take ownership
of the panels and of course customers
could also buy the panels outright from
solarcity
but the renting model is what was unique
to solar city
and would drew attention to the company
not only did this model make solar
panels much more attainable for the
average person
but it also allowed solar city to build
up a significant stream of recurring
revenue
throughout the next couple of years this
innovative model would allow solarcity
to aggressively expand
across california and a dozen other
states but
despite this rapid expansion the leasing
model proposed two major drawbacks
that would eventually crush the business
first of all
solar city had to front about forty
thousand dollars for each ppa
installation
which drove them into massive debt the
hope was that the recurring revenue
would eventually be so big
that the installation expenses wouldn't
be that big of a deal
but accomplishing this requires extreme
economies of skill
which solarcity was never able to reach
an even bigger problem though was that
leasing solar panels from solar city
wasn't actually that cost effective sure
it was cheaper than installing solar
panels yourself
in terms of upfront cost but it was way
more expensive
over the long term by switching to solar
the idea is to completely eliminate your
monthly electric bill
or at least significantly reduce it
however
when you pay rent for the solar panels
and the fixed rate for the electricity
the panels produce
solar city not only didn't lower your
electric bill but it often even made it
more expensive than simply buying
electricity
from the grid to make things even worse
you don't even get the tax benefits for
using solar
since solar city owns the solar panels
they get the solar credits
considering this the people leasing from
solar city were primarily
doing it as an environmental move as
opposed to a financial move
despite these fundamental issues with
the business model there were a lot of
people who were interested
nonetheless and this allowed solar city
to continue their rapid expansion
in 2012 solar city went public at eight
dollars per share
and the stock exploded 47 on the first
day of trading
by 2014 solar city was killing it
they had racked up 70 000 customers they
owned one third of the residential
market
and they were completing more
installations than their next 50 biggest
competitors
combined considering their dominance
it's not surprising to hear that their
stock had grown over 10x to 86 dollars
per share
once again though there were major
issues under the hood
in order to keep up with exponential
growth the company put out extremely
ambitious sales goals
linden for instance proposed reaching 1
million installations by 2018
to keep up with these targets sales reps
started to become more
and more sleazy a former sales director
describes that the proposition was
just sign here don't worry you can
cancel any time
according to him people were tweeting it
like signing off on
itunes terms and conditions in other
words people had no idea what they were
getting into
and they weren't happy when they saw
their first bill the company's average
cancellation rate surged to 45
meanwhile the door-to-door sales team
had an average cancellation rate
of 70 solar city was also having an
extremely tough time funding their solar
installations
as the company continued to grow their
credit lines were drying up
and the company started to rely on
investments to keep their installations
going
at the same time solar city was also
facing massive external issues
first of all the 30 federal solar tax
credit was about to expire in 2015
which meant that solar city super high
insulation costs were about to balloon
another 30 percent fortunately the tax
credit would be extended
and at first it seemed like this was a
good thing for solarcity
but this was actually not the case
you see over the past 10 years solar
panel technology had
massively improved which radically drove
down the cost of installation
the average cost to buy and install
solar panels had dropped from about 40k
in 2006
to just about 20k by 2015. combine this
with a 30
tax credit and customers could now buy
their own solar panels for just about
thirteen thousand dollars so the appeal
for renting solar panels from solar city
was dwindling
and the company would be forced to
change their focus in february of 2016
the company announced that the core of
their business would shift to selling
and financing solar panels
as opposed to leasing them out this
would prevent their monthly recurring
revenue from growing
but it would help them deal with their
massive debt as well wall street however
was not convinced that solar city would
actually become profitable by making the
switch
and they will start dumping the stock
jim cramer famously stated that this was
the worst conference call
of 2016. as investors started to pull
the plug
solar city entered a financial crisis as
the company was relying on investment to
keep the lights on considering this dire
situation
elon would call linden in february 2016
and suggest combined tesla
and solar city elon would turn around
and propose the idea to tesla's board
as well but tesla's board really had no
interest in buying solar city
tesla themselves were burning 50 cents
for every one dollar of revenue
meanwhile solar city was burning six
dollars for every one dollar of revenue
so tesla acquiring solar city would no
doubt be a bailout
as a result they rejected elon's
proposal
in an effort to prop up solo city elon
would use reserves from spacex where he
had majority control
to buy 90 million worth of bonds from
solo city
elon would continue to pressure the
board to invest in solar city
and elon would get his way in june of
when tesla offered acquire solar city
for 2.8 billion dollars
solar city investors were ecstatic as
tesla was building the amount which
caused a stocked value 15 percent
most tesla investors weren't exactly
pleased as tesla stock would dump 10
after the announcement and this is when
elon would host that rather infamous
presentation
about the future of solar roofs at the
time
solar roofs were nowhere near ready to
be deployed in fact when elon saw the
prototype version of the solar roof
tiles
sources say that yellen told peter that
he was wasting his time
and that the product was a piece of crap
tesla would later clarify that elon
simply didn't like the first iteration
and that he actually liked the
underlying concept
itself anyway despite knowing that solar
roofs weren't quite ready
he would come on stage and pitch the
idea in order to use tensions with tesla
investors
who were strongly against acquisition
fortunately for elon shareholders would
approve the acquisition in november
and tesla would acquire the company
later that month after the acquisition
solar city or now tesla solar would go
on to fire 3 000 employees
or about 20 of their workforce tesla
would also place heavy focus on shifting
away from the leasing model
and instead focusing on selling panels
over the next few years
tesla solar's revenue from solar panel
sales would increase from just 2 percent
to 31 it should be noted though that
during this time period
tesla solos installations dropped by 40
so tesla was completing far fewer
installations
but the installations they did complete
were purchases as opposed to leases
in the meantime linden would leave the
company in 2017
citing that it was time for him to move
on to this day
lyndon hold that solar city didn't need
a bailout from tesla
he claims that solar city could have
easily raised more money and stood up by
themselves
while that may be true there's no
question that tesla made it magnitudes
easier for the business
to survive today tesla solar is still
not quite profitable
and the vast majority of the revenue
comes from selling and installing
regular old solar panels
however tesla has recently been able to
absorb the losses from the solar
division
and still be profitable with the rising
popularity of tesla cars
many tesla owners have also expanded to
buying tesla solar panels along with
tesla power walls
this has allowed solar city to take on a
new and refreshed form
with a much brighter future tesla has
also started to roll out their fancy
solar roofs
but this is still super limited not to
mention
extremely expensive on my house for
example
buying regular tesla solar panels would
cost twenty four thousand six hundred
dollars
buying the fancy solar roof however
would cost sixty two thousand
three hundred fifty four dollars so
clearly tesla has a long way to go
in terms of making a solar roof
affordable for the masses
but as tesla's core business continues
to grow and generate more profits
and as solar technology continues to
improve hopefully
we will eventually see tesla solar reach
elon's vision and substantiate the
efforts
of solar city do you guys have a
positive opinion on solarcity
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are rooting for tesla solar
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one